what is the business of vincent going to
be and for people who
don't know you can go to with
vincent.com
to go ahead and start searching all
these different assets that are on there
and that
is a delightful experience i will say
that and it does keep you up to date and
familiarize yourself with that but
that's not a giant business what is the
big business idea here
in terms of business model so we have
over a hundred thousand
uh investors that have already used it
over a million searches over 75
platforms that were already partnered
with
and we have something that's unique that
no one else has is we know what people
are looking
at across the various assets very rarely
can you compare are you interested
in collectibles versus crypto and we
have those percentages
and it's very interesting to use that
because we're able to create an
experience
by having our design that people can go
from one asset to another in seconds as
opposed to logging into a new tab having
to do aml kyc
and figuring this all out so the average
user is looking at 25 deals
across seven platforms in three asset
classes in a matter of minutes
and that experience was not possible
before vincent and what we believe is if
we can still become
the trusted partner to the investors
there's a lot of monetization
opportunities
the obvious ones are potentially a sas
play off of the supply side which is the
originators
being able to get paid per click or
being able to get paid per lead
for the originators there's an investor
pro model that it's possible there's a
lot of investors are asking us to do
more and provide more feedback and more
diligence
and more support and the holy grail is
that we're able to leverage the data
that we're getting
to create potentially some proprietary
products which we're navigating all of
that
um we also already have some large banks
that are reaching out to us that want to
have access to our alternative
investment data
uh their pwm teams or their high net
worth teams
are trying to source unique deals for
their clients
or they want to be able to see this
quickly or understand the trends and we
have that trends and we have
access to the data quickly at our
platform so we're young we just launched
on november 1st
uh so i wouldn't say the monetization is
our number one thing i would call this
year a building here
but if we're able to become the
destination of where you think about
alts
so start with vincent uh we think
there's a lot of opportunities of how to
monetize
i think just normalizing the data is
also like a really
interesting component of this you will
you can sort hey i want real estate
deals hey i want deals that are high
alpha
or a lower return profile or potential
return profile
you can sort them by what the minimum
investment is right because some of the
minimums are
500 other ones are 50 000 so depending
on what your goals are uh and
you may want to see different types of
offerings so
in a way it's kind of like zillow or
redfin where
if you're searching you say you know you
really need four bedrooms because i got
three kids and i need a home office and
i don't even look at anything under four
bedrooms
and uh there's some normalization that
occurs here i wonder
about the community aspect to this have
you thought about
people discussing deals and handicapping
them et cetera
that's a great question and our product
queue and our prioritization
process is very active right now
we don't even have a share button yet
where you can even share the deals so
we're very early in our features
obviously
trying to get it out quickly and get
feedback definitely people are asking
for those opportunities to
communicate and i think what you've
mentioned in terms of the fetching is
something you need to
manage against to figure out how you
want to get ahead of it so yes we've
talked about discords or slacks
or able to have discussions right there
we've also been having some of that
dialogue
on twitter or do we push that into uh
other forums
that's still tbd i can tell you that
there definitely is
uh a market of folks that want to learn
they want to talk to each other they
want to share with each other because
we're seeing that
even with our pulse newsletter the
simplicity of pulling together the
the most interesting 15 articles in alts
across all of vault
and sending it out for free once a week
is something that we're getting love
notes back about oh this is so helpful
you saved me three hours of research
that i just don't
wouldn't want to have to do the work or
i would do it and i the fact that you
did this for me
in one email in a second is great and
back what you were saying about the
house the four bedrooms a perfect
example of that is
trading cards are very hot right now and
whether you're going to rally whether
you're going to collectible
whether you're going uh to otis whether
you're going to dibs whether you're
going to these other platforms you
want to know what are all my options and
it's not as if rally is going to tell
you what's on otis
and otis is not going to tell you what's
uncollectible but you know that you're
looking for a certain price deal but you
want to see all of them
you can just put that search in vince
and save it and we just send it to you
and there you have it
so your real estate broker might tell
you about certain homes
but they might leave out a couple
because oh they're getting they're
repping this home and they're selling it
they get the double commission whatever
it is they don't want competition
what about rating the deals and rating
the platforms
people do want to know what is the
performance of these and then maybe even
rating the process for example
with our syndicate we require monthly
updates from the founders and we
make sure the founders are willing to
take
uh questions directly from syndicate
members i.e you
you agreed to that as well bit of a pain
in the neck um
potentially um was what we were told it
turns out
it most founders found it delightful but
this idea of raiding the quality of the
platforms
are you gonna do that um or is that
another thing that could be
incredibly divisive yeah again this is
right in the product queue
and um the tricky part about that is yes
we're getting a lot of requests and
questions so part of it
is people know that the platform is a
good platform but they also appreciate
who the founders are
so they're almost asking us like oh
would you invest into this should i
invest in this yeah and
the balancing act there is outside of
those bits and bytes of the actual
software we have to make sure we're
navigating
the sec rules around advisory and
what are we allowed to say and what are
we not allowed to say and is this an
accredited deal
that we're marketing potentially to
folks uh or is this not a credit where
anybody can have access to it
so we definitely want to find our
solution there there's a potential for
um a kind of vincent pro offering
yeah where you'll be able to sign up for
a certain amount of money a month
that you will get access to uh more
proprietary diligence
where you'll have analysts
per deal per vertical uh what's hot
where is it trending
um and and that's the sort of thing that
we'll know once you're behind the wall
we'll know you signed up um and we just
need to manage
make sure we're doing it correctly from
a regulatory perspective
but again off the foundation of the
search engine and off the foundation of
having objective
information and not having to push our
own stuff
is a really unique place in the market
and that's why we think we could be the
on-ramp
for alternatives every startup needs to
ensure they own their intellectual
property
or ip for short and that starts with
filing your trademarks
i have two trademarks that are very
let's call it generic everyday words
launch
and inside people create confusing
products all the time
and trademarks are critically important
so that i can maintain
control of my brand if you don't know
where to start look
no further than brain based file it's a
clean simple and automated trademark
filing platform that gives
anyone the ability to protect their best
ideas there is no need to spend
thousands of dollars on lawyers
to file your trademark for you now you
can do everything for yourself
in a few easy steps brain based file
gives you goods and services
recommendations using ai
so you can avoid back and forth with the
us patent and trademark
office and you can eliminate all that
human error that can happen they offer
full transparency into the uspto process
again
patent and trademark office with
step-by-step notifications and
real-time updates on your trademarks
approval you want to know where your
trademark is in the process and they do
a great job of keeping you up to date on
that let's be honest no one likes
dealing with trademarks
but brain based file makes it easy so
head to brainbase.com
twist and enter the code twist at
checkout to file your first trademark
now for just a hundred and sixty nine
dollars that's a 15
discount thanks to my friends at brain
base for giving us that discount
brain base dot com slash twist and
remember to use the offer code twist
okay let's get back to this amazing
episode